MARK MIRCHANDANI:
This week, we're
talking about the
Cloud Network Engineer
Certification, the Cloud
Run button, and BigQuery.
I'm Mark.
And welcome to "This
Week in Cloud,"
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Obtaining and maintaining
professional certifications
is a big part of a successful
career, even more so
with one of the latest Google
Cloud certifications, the Cloud
Network Engineer Certification.
If you're looking for
the best way to prepare,
you'll want to step up to
the plate with this guide
from Tom Taggart, a solution
architect at Google Cloud.
Tom talks more about
his home run method
to prepare for the
certification and best practices
for studying.
Get ready for a grand slam
with this great guide.
Cloud Run lets you
deploy containerized
serverless applications
without having
to worry about operations,
scalability, or security.
Now it's even easier to share
your code with the Cloud Run
button, a one-click process for
people looking at your Git repo
to deploy your app to Cloud Run.
Just make sure your
code has a Dockerfile
or uses Cloud Native
Buildpacks, and copy
the button into the readme.
BigQuery lets you analyze
tremendous amounts
of data quickly thanks
to some great tech,
including partitioning
and clustering.
You can customize these
in your BigQuery data sets
based on your typical usage to
reduce data shuffling, which
will also help you improve
performance and lower cost.
Check out this blog post
that explains more about
how clustering works, and
then try it out for yourself.
With your BigQuery
data organized,
your next step might
be to automate.
Thanks to the BigQuery
module for Terraform,
it's now easier than ever
to have your infrastructure
as code automate your
datasets and tables.
See the details and follow along
to get your BigQuery structure
declared and deployed.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.